hey guys it's the evident Kaitlyn well
just right now having an Evan podcast
cuz Kaitlyn this tax Tina I'm not
texting I'm replying to comments I'm
doing work I didn't know we were
recording yet we have a really exciting
podcast even though Kaitlyn is still
texting we are gonna be talking about
sponsors it's a topic we get a lot of
questions about I'm sure it's not gonna
be our last sponsor there's so much to
talk about
Podcast yeah so um again this podcast
will be enhanced by a little interview
that we did with Donnybrook it's gonna
be about 15 minutes of this podcast
Jonny Brooke really opened our eyes to
working with sponsors more how to reach
out to them how to integrate more
sponsors into one videos and when we did
our collaboration with him where we made
the flat-pack live-edge C&C
coffee table thing aka that all the
keywords table all the keywords table we
got a lot of tips on woodworking from
him but I think that one of the biggest
things for us was how he worked with
sponsors so it felt appropriate to wrap
him up into this podcast because he is
wrapping him up we are also going to UM
play would you rather who do you rather
so excited be like playing another game
with you
so I guess before we go into the
interview we'll introduce you guys to
Johnny in case you don't know who he is
fidgeting and making noises well I I
have like a fun story we did a
collaboration with Johnny and was that
one of the first time they stayed with
another user yeah it was the first time
we stayed with at another youtubers
house when we were collaborating it was
so great telling my parents about this
we were like uh so you're gonna stay at
the friend yeah yeah yeah and she's like
have you met him and we're like oh we
chatted on behind and we've watch each
other's videos we know each other yeah
we met on the
she's like here's gonna staying at his
house so natural to us and it was we
just like showed up we were like we
instantly greeted by two cats yeah
kaylynn was instantly at home yes but I
also think it's crazy because in these
videos you really show a lot of who you
are and you share a lot so since he had
watched our videos and we had to watched
his videos and we had chatted a little
bit a little bit beforehand it was such
like a really the connection that had
already been made almost yeah like you
feel like you know each other and you
kind of forget like oh yeah we have it
how I'm actually actually met in person
but it felt like we have hung out a lot
yeah yeah that is so crazy and we're
like yeah we're you know just staying in
a person's basement so Johnny Brook runs
a YouTube channel called crafted
workshop mm-hmm he actually if if you
want for Cather workshop the YouTube
channel he ran contra workshop magazine
yeah which was a magazine that he ran by
himself I think somehow magically yeah
oh and before that he was in marketing
yeah and so he like has a really great
mind for I mean for marketing like for
and and that's a lot of what you do and
I'm not talking about so much I mean
part of the marketing you do is a
youtuber when you're working with
sponsors is like showing off their
product to people but a huge part of it
is marketing yourself to sponsors and I
feel like he's really really good at
that well and at the same time he used
to be the person that would buy these
advertising deals he would make like
decisions like this so he knows on the
other side how to sell since he was the
buyer yeah on the other side yeah which
is great it's a great position to be in
yeah it's crazy um so on his channel he
does majority woodworking he's been
venturing into CNC metal printing and
metalworking and
his videos are just really informative
and we learned a lot while we were
collaborating with him yeah if you want
to land B oh oh just tool Envy video
it's yeah it's something that he has
built up over all these years through
all these deals through all these
connections so it's like he worked for
it oh I'm not suggesting he is he didn't
I'm just saying he's got some really
nice cool collaboration we come back
like wanting stuff whether it's like
tools or camera equipment or whatever we
come back wanting stuff and I think
after the collab with Johnny there were
the most things on our list did you get
we didn't get all of them yeah and
another thing that he does so well is he
works really efficiently you know he
films efficiently he does all of his
time management efficiently he has time
so like in the interview we talked about
sponsors but we also asked some
questions around how he does what he
does yeah in recent history and recently
had a baby but you know it wasn't like
that super recent and then it anyways I
[Applause]
[Music]
mean know how to use a microphone I mean
yeah I do want to kick it off healin
yeah first one I'm gonna ask you we're
gonna get like kind of real right
innovating I'm and it's just cuz I'm
very curious about it how things changed
since you had a baby yeah it's funny uh
not as much as I thought they would
yeah it's uh he's first of all he's an
amazingly easy baby we got very lucky
okay so instructions for a baby not
about your work like having a baby yeah
have a good day mom's on call it's like
practically a baby manual and yeah it's
like totally like detailed scheduling on
like a schedule they recommend for a
baby yeah and like at what kind of
months to change that and shift but he's
been sleeping through the night since he
was three months old
yeah like seven to seven so you're just
like following the instruction manual
baby okay
so that and then we also have an awesome
nanny actually our first Nate broke her
hip oh my gosh crazy oh no she was
amazing but now we got new nanny who's
also amazing so that between those two
things I mean you know basically the
nanny comes like 8:30 in the morning I
go down to the shop I work till about
5:30
Cindy gets home about 5:00 and you know
I get a full day in and I don't really I
wasn't working at night before much
anyway so like I've always been a very
kind of like nine-to-five I try to keep
my work-life balance
very tight unlike some people I might
know very smoothly then how do you do
that because we literally work probably
from when we wake up to go to bed
there's two of us well you guys do a lot
more than I do so stop doing so much
video well it's kind of it's usually
like like three months and I'm actually
probably gonna be slowing that down even
like I'm probably like two months
because the other thing is like last
year I kind of over committed with my
sponsors and I needed to make a lot of
videos by the end of the year to be able
to fulfill those yes you know and so it
led me to making some smaller stuff
which I still liked but it's just not
like to me I want to be building like
really cool pieces of furniture and
stuff like that like I know that's that
was like the reason I started doing this
stuff so I think given myself a little
bit more breathing room and I don't know
it seems like other people are having
success too like like Brad only puts out
like two videos a month yeah killing you
know so I feel like you don't have to do
the weekly thing it's I think it's a
good like basic format you know yeah but
it just seems like it's just crazy it's
hard hard to keep that out I was adding
a lot of stress to my life it is
interesting seeing because I mean you
know a year ago two years ago it seems
like YouTube is really rewarding like
daily better and now we're seeing
creators like
Dawson is doing something once every
couple of months and it is amazing
well I am Wang I'm asking like like
people in our space like Frank ours and
like it's all Tony like they're making
like especially this old Tony he's
making like 25 to 30 minute long videos
yeah releasing them on no set schedule
so just kind of when they are up and get
awesome views you know so I think I
think in the end of the day doing what
makes you happy rather than trying to
fit your life to some schedule that is
you know laid out by not even YouTube
just by people thinking they know you
know what I mean like yeah that's the
thing it's all speculation well I think
another thing that will let us do that I
think it's when you're in that hustle
phase when you're in that growth totally
the more the more you do the more you're
rewarded yeah you know and and every new
video is an opportunity for growth I
think that we're still in that mindset
still even though I think we're past
that like tipping point early you know
we're full-time are our you know we're
making enough to be fine yep and
anything any further growth is amazing
more better more better better you know
like it's like it's like a game you know
you trying to do bigger things you can
start podcasts and do all sorts of crazy
there's only get it but I think you also
at some point you guess about like your
personal well-being we've started
convincing ourselves that we're gonna
only do three sponsored commitments per
month yeah and the problem is thankfully
I mean we're really in the lucky
position that we've scheduled everything
so far out but we're six months
scheduled out now I know we can't make
any changes yeah once you start
especially when you start reducing them
or videos you put out it's like oh well
I'm set through June yeah but it's also
kind of nice because then instead of
having to deal with a bunch of sponsors
every day just go build what you want to
build and do you think but then do you
ever deal with like you get an idea
you're super excited about it you want
to do it but you can't do it for five
months yeah
definitely happens but I just shuffle
stuff I think you do it like even if
I've got like three videos that I think
I'm gonna make next month
I've got something else that comes up
like we're actually probably gonna be
moving here soon building setting up my
workshop part 12 exactly what's it like
having a new space now it's like oh we
needed a little kitchen table and we
need you know like a little gate for the
steps and like you know all these little
projects so you know just kind of
shuffle things around because I think
with a lot of sponsors it doesn't matter
exactly what project it is it's more you
know as long as their product maybe fits
into it yeah now you try to keep your
projects as vague as possible when you
pitch them to sponsors or do you kind of
commit to a specific thing yeah I keep
it super vague like usually I don't even
we should do that some are usually not
even I don't know it depends on the
sponsor yeah but like like my yearly
people you know like like my rocklers
and Powermatic like I don't tell them
what I'm building I know that doesn't
make it more fun you sell them the video
when it's done like when it's live yeah
like they have zero input and after you
kind of nice as you layer sponsors does
it get more complicated to do that I
guess yeah I think a lot of my sponsors
are very kind of symbiotic and they they
kind of work together well you know like
like the power maddox and the rocklers
is ya know a lot of these brands that
they don't step on each other's toes
yeah they all fit in pretty much any
project I build like if I'm doing
anything my shop I'm using Powermatic
stuff yeah I'm using Rockler stuff you
know it's like inherent in the project
whatever it is you're gonna learn that
work yeah so specific things like like
if it's a like an epoxy project things
like that that's a little bit more
specific you know or you know like some
of the stuff for Low's like they wanted
me to use like certain tools yeah
whatever
but even then like one of the things
like one of the tools they want to be
used as a tape measure stuff like that
even even with them it was like we need
use this drill and impact driver what
project don't not use a drive impact
driver on you know so so I'm curious how
many how many sponsors have you layered
into one video
like you're like record director yeah I
think for for okay yeah I wonder if
anyone's ever done five it's all about
that product place it's a win-win-win it
is you know I mean yeah like you're
using the tool that you believe in yep
so it's good for your audience you're
gonna make more videos that's good for
body and see I'm gonna show the brand
off it's good for the brand and then we
gonna make the videos when we winds are
rare yes they are and I think that we
can make that happen which is cool when
I think that's why I like when you do
sponsored content like being thoughtful
about yeah thoughtful about the
companies you work with you know cuz
otherwise it's really easy to have
conflicts you know there's some brands
that are clear competitors and then you
know the other thing is like working
with stuff you like and not like trying
to force yourself to use a tool that you
aren't really happy with yeah I look
forward to ABS when I'm like I gotta
tell people about a thing that I love
you know um Squarespace yeah you see
I've been using swears names for like
two years
you know like stuff like that's easy
it's not hard to do you have any and
without saying the brand because I don't
want any you have any like crazy horror
stories I think just some of the bigger
companies sometimes get a little bit
ridiculous with some of their requests
like as far as like how much lead time
they want on approval or like some of
the like exclusivity stuff or like their
h paid contracts more than that oh my
gosh teen 15 page like it's crazy yeah
like wow I do laugh when someone's like
yeah we'd like 30 days late I know how
you to work 30 hours yeah
maybe definitely guarantee me so that's
19 that's just these large companies and
all these yeah you know huge legal teams
and I don't think it's you know their
fault necessarily it's just I think
that's part of being a massive you know
corporation yeah sad sad I mean most
inria li easy I mean yeah it's a it's
kind of amazing how how easy it is to
like get in with some of these brands
and then they become you know you're
kind of regular supporters yeah it's it
makes this whole side of things a lot
less stressful you know like if I was
really worried about filling odd spots
like that that's a big financial burden
you got when that's like a big part of
your business models income stream yeah
for us it's like sixty percent yeah yeah
yeah I think one thing that we picked up
from you when we did our collaboration
together is layering sponsors finding
that synergy and I think that's one
thing that you do a lot differently than
some people yeah are there any other
tips that you see people just like why
do you do that well I think one thing
people do is like they give away
exclusivity of their ad with with like
the brand didn't even ask for it yeah
like I don't ever assume that they don't
want me to serve any other ads yeah I
mean like I just do it I've literally
never had an issue like as long as
they're not a conflicting brand yeah I
don't think they care yeah as far you
know so like some brands might specify
that but I would say most do not
yeah and if they don't and why would you
like offer that or bring that and I mean
like and then they're gonna expect it
and then that's gonna be what they
expect you do every time I have this
assumed hesitation that if I do if we do
like two different
taught like I don't I can layer product
placements all day always have like a
hesitation about doing like two girls
mid-roll yeah those are a little
trickier I know you've been you know
you've done it long enough that
your audience I think if they see two
they don't think anything of it but in
the beginning was that something where
you got pushed back I usually only do
that if it's a longer video you know so
like I think for me I've always run up
against like okay do I split this into a
two parter and then have one mineral in
each or do I just keep it a long video
yeah it's long and you should have two
minerals and yeah like what about is it
on TV and a 30-minute episode 20 minutes
of content ten minutes of a pretty good
usually my breaks are like 30 seconds
yeah so it's the picture-in-picture so
yeah I mean I think I don't know I
haven't had that much blowback I mean
especially I'm like my commentaries I
think on like Reddit and stuff yeah we
definitely learned that lesson early on
we did a few posts before we started to
use your channel did it amazing yeah we
did a professional post yep oh no no
yeah it's uh it's a little bit different
but you know they're they're very unique
cup of tea but yeah especially the
people in this space understand that
they're getting free content that's
high-quality yeah they're learning
something they're being entertained yeah
and that the small price they have to
pay is to sit through 30 seconds I also
feel like in this space in particular
more than maybe some other communities
on YouTube I feel like it is a lot
easier to monetize when you're smaller
we were surprised at how small we were
when we started and 20 or 30 yeah like
20 or 30 K yeah and I think it's just
because it is so natural to integrate
some of the brands that we work with
whereas maybe if you're like a comedy
channel or something there's not being
so easy to it well we use a lot of
products yeah and I think all these are
curious about it yeah I think you know
I'm a total tool nerd you know the tool
I love stuff I love getting new gear for
my shop you know so it's really not very
hard like it's a problem cardboard box
situation is yeah
I don't want to keep you away from your
touch much a good podcast little tips
that we didn't get into that that I feel
like are a good starting point for
people thinking about working with
sponsors one we feel pretty strongly
that there's no need for companies to
reach out to you yeah no need for you to
like wait for that mm-hmm yeah now I
think that there are a lot of people who
do feel strongly about that but in our
experience about half the sponsors we
work with are companies that we have
reached out to yes I mean I will present
the counter like one of the main counter
arguments I guess the two counter
arguments to what we do if you if you
reach out to sponsors you know there's a
potential that you lose some of the
power and the negotiation because they
already know that you want to work with
them and then there's also the issue of
you know you may not hear back from them
so it could be wasted time but I think
in our experience it's worth it still
mm-hm
despite those potential downsides I
totally agree and I think that one the
biggest benefit of reaching out to
companies is you know what companies you
love you know a company is you could
given like an honest recommendation for
and I think those make the best ads that
feels the best to your audience
it's the most natural fit and being able
to do that like we reach out to
companies that we have been using for
eight years and some of our videos and
really we've used them for eight years
and we've been very happy and like that
is it feels good to do an ad like that I
will say it's kind of hard like the best
case scenario is there's a company out
there that you see is already like kind
of in the sponsorship game and they know
how it works because it is sometimes
hard working with companies who had
never sponsored content that's true that
they don't know how much to pay for what
they get
they don't have they don't have the
right expectation not like pre-approved
to do it you know like like the
marketing person your top your talking
to him I think it's a great idea but
they have to send it up the line and get
approval or you could help them craft
their marketing campaign and you could
be there like person that they go to
they they say like hey you guys helped
us do this it went well we got good
clicks good return for that let's do
more and if you can't do all of it you
can like you know like recommend them to
the right people that you think would be
a good fit which is awesome because then
you're bringing another company into the
space that can help lots of other people
yeah it is a really good marketing like
return for these companies I don't know
where I've told the story I feel like
I've told this multiple times but we
have talked with people at different
companies who have told us how much they
spend to get a video professionally
produced which involves renting a space
writing the script it's like the cost go
up and up and up and up and up and these
videos might cost $30,000 $100,000 and
and and when the company pushes it out
it's like being shoved out there towards
people people don't appreciate that
message as much it doesn't mean as much
and so hard it feels like a commercial a
lot of the times and both our
commercials in the way but I feel like
does it I mean yeah but also it's like
if it's the right match between a
company and a person writing and
producing the app like us yeah we can do
it on such a smaller budget and it's a
genuine endorsement because we're like
we use this it's good it's like you know
in more words but it's it's great
because it means more and I don't know
yeah so definitely like don't be afraid
to reach out to sponsors if that's
something you want to do yeah and I
think that reaching out with a specific
idea is like super key like
if you like sell them on the whole story
of it - mm-hmm yeah well also cuz like
imagine you're in the sponsors position
and you get an email from you know
multiple people you know that are trying
to get you to pay them to make stuff
essentially the ones that are gonna
stand out are the people who actually
have a cool idea that you can
immediately picture in your mind you
know cuz then you have something to say
yes to if you can say if like all they
have to say is yes that's that's ideal
instead of saying oh yeah it cuts out an
email and it shows that also you've put
actual thought into it
mhm you know like you're not just
copying and pasting the same email to
everybody even though you can kind of
when you're starting out you might
notice that in the videos that we're
doing back then we would sometimes you
know incorporate the tool or but cereal
or whatever more tightly into the
project and when you're smaller I think
that that's an extra selling point that
you can do to distinguish yourself as
long as it still feels natural for your
channel and then yeah we still do that
now so much it's just now we also have a
mix of Laguerre I don't know maybe half
and half or one-third two-thirds yeah
there's like two types of sponsors kinds
where they're not related to the project
at all and they don't even really care
and there's the ones
yeah like Squarespace trade coffee those
kind of sponsors or there's the ones
that are you know based on like a tool
or material like Arbortech total boat
and Venables yeah exactly so pitching an
idea or like when you're saying like do
you like making it easy for them to say
yes so it's a specific tool or brand you
might have to tell your project more but
if it's like a company where it's more
nebulous I think you could still pitch
the idea like even with Squarespace when
we were reaching out to them we had a
specific website in mind a specific
strategy for how we would talk about
things and
the story and I think that that makes
you stand out a little more yeah that's
true we do do that so I think that that
one one stumbling point that some people
don't know how to get over is how to
reach out to those companies and there's
a lot of different strategies you can
you know reach out via Instagram you can
reach out via Twitter social media
person even if they're not the exact
person who's gonna say yet be able to
say yes or no to sponsoring you they're
probably in the same department yeah but
I think that another thing that really
helps with that you need to stand out
again especially if it's company that it
gets inundated with requests or free
products or advertising or etc etc like
maybe use their products a little bit to
them show them that you're willing to
put in a little bit of advance work
maybe if they follow you then you can
stand out a little bit more and say hey
I notice you followed me you're you know
like yeah yeah I've really been enjoying
a product or don't say hey I see follow
me that's weird connection especially if
it's like a product or something that
you already haven't use just tag them
when you use it and see what happens
yeah I think that another thing you can
do is you know some people have had
success with just calling the company
and asking for their like marketing
person that's a little bit forward for
us we haven't done that also you know
try to find the marketing email address
online which is totally possible we've
done that before - that was a tip we got
from Johnny actually when we did our
collaboration right emails yeah yeah
it's called you just need a marketing
person to find a marketing person they
might be able to send
the correct mark if you don't get the
right one at first another really great
way to make those relationships and make
those connections is by going to events
meeting the people at events and people
out the vents are the people you want to
talk to they're usually the social media
people and I think that getting that
impression you know coming in with that
like easy yes for them to say the same
strategy is about like make that
connection by like showing up at the
events and having you know conversation
with them it shows that you're more
serious about it I think yeah I mean we
could probably go on for this okay one
more tip we didn't write this down on
our notes of things to talk about but
another one that I think helps you stand
out is make a media kit you know what I
think that that does help in some
situations but in other situations it
might come across as impersonal I don't
know I think it helps there's like mixed
messages from like social media people
about you know marketing kids because
some people say no some people say yeah
no I don't know I've never heard that I
heard of that work that's gone really
yeah well like no well I think that
their point was it it you know might
come across as impersonal presumptuous
or what-have-you
I think that you know if you just have
like I think that maybe what they're
saying no to is your prices and your
packages on the media kit that's
something that people go back and forth
on is it just maybe kind of like hey
here's some of our projects here's our
demographics here's our prices are
optional I think the main things to
include in a media kit and and like we
don't send the media kit automatically
we usually send it on request yeah have
one cuz some companies will request one
yes perhaps you should go ahead and make
one just in case cuz you'll eventually
get asked but but have things like your
social media stats you know like all the
important ones paragrafix size follows
engagement and maybe like a few types of
integrations that you're interested in
doing so like sponsorships and product
placements are the two those exclusivity
yeah or exclusivity deals and then also
you can have and this is especially good
once you've worked with a handful of
brands so you can have a section with
other brands you've worked with we even
like will screenshot comments if they're
like oh I signed up for someone so
whatever and thank you for everyone who
does that if you use a little the
products and you leave a comment then
we're like oh that's good I'm gonna show
that to the brand were like you know you
can put those little kind of like
testimonials yeah in your media kit yeah
well and also I think that that you know
we we are eventually going to do like a
whole YouTube video on how to get your
channel started and how to monetize and
what kind of monetizing options
yeah then just sponsors yeah but if you
have any questions on this you know
we're 100% open to revisiting this in
the future so go ahead and leave those
questions in the comments yeah of the
YouTube video is the best place to leave
the comments I think yeah comments of
the YouTube video for this is that even
if you're like listening on your in your
car or something go to the video and
leave them there because I think that's
where they say about the most people can
engage with them people can like you
know it's a good community place to
exist
I'm just saying words that don't make
sense don't bother me fine don't mind me
I think let's move on to the game to the
game
[Music]
okay so Kaitlyn would you rather have
x-ray vision or super hearing but the
caveat is you can't turn off either ever
what okay well I have a question about
x-ray vision this is something I've
always wondered yeah me too
where does the x-ray stop where does it
stop you see forever
yeah dude I see forever and they were
like what cuz like if you look think of
an x-ray yeah it's just like you see
dense things right or do you like
overlap your visual and the x-ray x-ray
let's say like someone's getting a
abdomen x-ray yeah you see their bones
and stuff but you don't see through them
to the wall behind them yeah so like a
cross-sectional scan through things that
might be like yeah but that's not x-ray
vision well I think of x-ray vision I
just see like seeing through things and
okay so let's let's maybe like do a
weird like guess down x-ray vision let's
say that you can see from here 30 feet
in front of you you can see through all
of it wouldn't it just be confusing
that would be super confusing cuz I get
always seeing in like 3d but you see all
the layers of everything so it's like
all the layers you would see through all
of them and see that layer 30 feet away
no no no from here to 30 feet everything
between your eyes and 30 feet from them
that's the next time you see all of it
no that's not x-ray cuz like if you look
through an x-ray
you're not seeing like the skin the
muscle this is that you're seeing
straight to the bone no so what you're
seeing is your justing everything dense
between you and when the like so it's
like radiation is shot from a source to
a collection that's plate so if you see
from here 2:30 okay but even seeing that
you still wouldn't be seeing everything
from here you couldn't see your phone
you can see like wait no a phone is
dense yeah but like all your fuses to
block you can't see the visual spectrum
it's just like solid vision
shot like a den slumping so he could
give like confirmed that x-ray vision
sucks this is more of like too bad
scenario or use like here everything
let's say like in 500 feet you hear
everything and 500 feet you hear like
all the bugs all of the people talking
all of the conversations lose your
vision or you go insane okay I think I
think I would take the hearing do you
think you take the yeah yeah because you
can still function you can somewhat
function you could put any earplugs and
mute it slightly but those are two
persons yes definitely to Cougars on the
first thinking superpowers the like if
you can't turn them off that's bad that
sucks
I think if I well but like what what's
hilarious is we've also in our
discussion like have figured out that
even if you could turn off x-ray vision
like what even is x-rays yeah I mean cuz
that's when you think of like the
superhero music like okay I know that
like there could be magic just like
magically makes things happen but if you
think about like you know kind of like
how the last would you rather with the
fire and the ice and the magic and
everything while trying to explain like
it through logic I'm trying to think of
like superpowers through logic think
about superpowers so it's like actually
a vision you like you can detect all the
ambient radiations and your eyes are
collectors for that if you're trying to
like pull off a heist or something it
would be useful if you were like just a
thief all the time that's how Xavier
works
[Laughter]
okay well I think that this conversation
is thoroughly derailed okay so I'll go
with hearing to cuz this it seems more
contraction vision just seems like you
just wouldn't be able to see things
normally yeah but like hearing it's it
it feels like you could still have some
control over muting it okay okay
side side question you know there's
always like the would you rather with
your senses would you rather lose your
vision or lose your hearing that's hard
mm-hmm I would probably lose my hearing
I feel like cuz I lose my hearing too I
could learn sign language make up for
that yeah I think it'd be hard to lose a
lot of your independence if you couldn't
see I feel like you'd lose a lot more
independence yeah yeah at least like at
this age my heart I don't like a learn
how to function I know it's possible but
yeah yeah okay medium yeah sad okay
would you rather accidentally upload a
video or your butt crack is showing or
accidentally upload a video or you drop
an f-bomb butt crack yeah yeah cause
like people watch with their kids and
stuff and so much crack a little crack
in there one day it's gonna happen one
day okay so this is this is like a true
truly a gift if you could have one of
these so would you rather never get spam
emails again or never get spam phone
calls again alright I see both stink so
bad yeah I think I would rather never
get cuz you think one I think is the
other here Oh booth
evils have always been coming in and
spam calls have been increasing like
that the amount that they are is not
gonna increase further cuz like you
can't say that but one is increasing
more because we don't know how it's like
so at this moment at this moment I think
I would take no spam emails hmm and I
say that because like in a day to day
basis there's a lot more real emails
coming in than real calls the number of
people that actually call me for actual
calls is very small and I don't just
know like if it's one of these numbers
in my phone it's good and if it's not I
can just ignore it and I feel like it
takes less mental processes even though
it's annoying but I feel like with your
email there's more sorting that you have
to do more decision-making more
decision-making yeah more choices
because we do get emails from people we
don't know that are legit emails but I
don't often get calls from people I
don't know that our legit calls you know
what I mean yeah yeah it's like if it's
a legit call we generally know we like
expect it or we have their number or
something like that
exactly yeah or like yeah if you have a
doctor's appointment coming up you
should probably answer it if your car's
in the shop
you should probably answer unknown
numbers yeah for a period of time and
then it goes back to rejecting everyone
you don't know sorry I do get more
annoyed at like spam calls than I do
with spam leeches because it does feel
more intrusive how dare you both are
like technically somewhat illegal but
like phone calls are like legit like
you're not supposed to do that I do it
they do it yeah it's bad
okay I think both of us would be emails
yeah yeah oh I didn't answer my butt
crack one okay um
would you would you rather never be able
to use a touchscreen again or never be
able to use a keyboard and mouse again
touchscreen keyboard mouse are alike the
precise they're fast and everything and
that that means like a phone I wouldn't
use a phone like you can get a phone
with a keyboard a keyboard and of stylus
yeah so then you can still function
Atlas cuz I'm not using touchscreen
because I you can't do work you you work
on a computer in a phone it's like
supplemental yeah and one thing that I
was thinking is even if you took away
your little workaround there I think I
would still pick touchscreen because I
feel like it's probably healthy to like
like you could definitely get by and
still get the work done that needs to
get done by not doing work on a on a
phone you know yeah like you could just
say when I'm at the computer I'm looking
at screen and if I'm not at a computer
I'm not doing screen time yeah you know
unless it's like like watching YouTube
the crazy thing is there are some apps
now that are very crucial to our
day-to-day as a business like Instagram
doesn't have a Chromebook with it yeah
yeah would you rather never get
demonetized or never get copyright
strikes right
[Music]
what so I'm trying to think so I feel
like like some making the same content
that we make know like like suddenly
just go crazy posting like crazy content
yeah I feel like so when you say do you
monetize do you mean like the video good
see monetize do you mean though like
Auto D monetization that pops up but
then you can combat it is yes okay and
the copier strike is like then like when
we do these song epitome
I would rather not get copy struck me
too I feel like if we get a de
monetization claim reason or it's false
I'm thinking it's probably false because
everyone that's been on us has been
false and only request manual review it
said it was fine well it's also so scary
right now because literally everybody's
getting copy struck like yes mr. beast
that like sang like part of it and he
got copy struck for singing it yeah and
then there's another big youtuber who
got copy striked because of like no
reason at all and the person who copied
struck him was a channel that had one
subscriber I saw that one subscriber
it's like how like like can you just
like it's just crazy scary because
anybody can just do it to anybody and
Google repercussions unless you sue them
yeah court in order to resolve these
things and I know that it shouldn't be
on YouTube to make these legal decisions
maybe and it gets really complicated
because like then YouTube is like a
judge and jury yes I understand why they
can't they are now putting in place like
if you try to copyright strike someone
and it doesn't work and you know you can
prove it and everything then you might
get that privilege taken away from you
but like as a big channel if coffee
striking someone is too easy then anyone
can just go in and just harass people
and it's just and it's really painful
that harassment you know so it's a
problem and I don't know what the
solution is yeah so definitely
protect myself against that it feels
like like somebody doesn't like your
channel or if they feel like they can
make some money off of you they just do
it they can just do it yeah it's crazy
would you rather be well-liked when
you're alive but disliked after your
death or disliked while you're alive and
well liked after your death liked while
I'm live cuz pretty easy I don't know
and I think that does that include your
family and relatives and people who live
on after you great public opinion um I
know everyone everyone oh man
so it's like everyone loves you when
you're alive and as soon as you die your
family is like man that guy was but
[Laughter]
temper my in combination the worst but
cuz like geez like living your life
disliked but then like thinking about
like your legacy cuz you know I think
that you kind of do LaVon and the
memories of the people that you leave
behind and everything that it sting to
be but I don't know just live in your
life the best you can people liking you
yeah I mean I kind of feel the same but
it is weird it's like it would just suck
to live and no one likes you and you
know that or do you not know it while
your life is that knowledge I don't know
okay okay so oh you mean you don't know
yeah I thought you're asking do you know
that after you die it'll change yeah
like what wall you're living this great
life do you know that when you die
everyone's gonna hate you
so we're like you you you the you living
the life oh but you right now making the
decision no so as soon as you make it
you you forget that I don't know but I
think I agree I can agree yeah yeah I
agree with myself you top me okay
so wouldn't you rather have a phone that
never runs out of battery or a car that
never
out of gas when I thought of this I went
back and forth again and again and again
so I'm going I'm going
my first instinct was my first instinct
was gasps oh really my first instinct
was caught was phone my first instinct
was gas because the gas costs money we
don't know how much gas prices are gonna
go up in the future
yeah and the you know amount of
electricity to charge your phone is
negligible yeah so I was thinking class
what do you think about like how much do
you use something yeah
how important is phone time yeah and we
work from home right yeah I mean it was
why I was still commuting would
definitely be gas oh yeah yeah commuting
they'd be gas if we were in any other
situation and situation don't leave the
house you know I might still pick I
don't know how much they spend on gas
like it's basically is the amount we
spend on gas per month worth the hassle
of having to charge my phone what's so
funny is your decision matrix is
completely different than mine because
I'm doing it based on cost yeah yeah cuz
I'm just doing it kind of pretty much
based on convenience if I was doing it
on convenient 100% phone yeah but like
at the stage right and that's where I
finally got it and then I actually
decided on gas out of convenience
because I don't like filling up and even
though we don't do it much it's the sex
it's annoying and now that I have a good
phone yeah
then it's the phone now it's like my
phone like came up of the warning like
your phone's gonna die soon if with
normal use it's gonna die at 1 I am
based on your usage charging it at night
yeah that's that's whoo yeah it's not a
big deal chair like explores or if we're
going like out and in in what wielders
you know that the places with the cheese
and stuff
then then they'll change and probably to
the phone but since we live in a house
with power yeah it's really easy so I
think car yeah me too very different
very different reasons because it was
such a back and forth it wasn't like a
oh this for sure yeah you know yeah
slight inconvenience very slight first
world problems I have another first
world would you rather live without
internet for two weeks or live without
AC / heat for two weeks depends on where
we're living
assume the weather is not good it's not
good and no internet for a week means
like you can't even go to Starbucks no
internet anywhere no matter what you do
no no anyway you're stuck in your house
stuck in your house no internet or no AC
/ or no AC I'd say no AC / eat you do a
little bit because it's so painful it's
just like you feel like the world is
spinning without you and like all these
things are happening if they are
distraction what clean the house for
maybe a day film oh yeah like with this
could you could you prepare the world
for your absence yeah okay like I can I
can be sweaty for a week or I could be
cold for a week you either bundle up or
you put on shorts or shower showers you
know turn on some fans fans yeah
probably the situation that would suck
more would be like yeah that's would be
that would be that would be miserable
yeah we could do it go about your day
and function yeah yeah it's like be real
sweaty
when doing resin if you could only use
alcohol ink or pigments forever
which would it be pigments pigments that
was pretty fast you're not tempted
violate the clear things the colored
clear things because with pigments you
can't do clear not really
I know but with only alcohol you can't
do geodes yeah but you could just yeah I
think I do pigments - I think it's cuz
like I have more experience what I mean
the one the video the resin ocean island
serving god that's the first one we've
done that was primarily alcoholic yeah
and it was really cool but I feel more
comfortable with pigments and what is
more interesting I feel like that you
have more control
like how goings are cool because they
add that layer of chaos you know cuz
they just create these crazy cells and
stuff but I feel like I have a little
bit more control with the pigments and
like most excited about in the future
okay for just those guys of you
listening not not my birthday for those
of you just listening here we have some
cool like add-ins to resin on its way
like hollow glow-in-the-dark
like glow like edible oh yeah yeah we're
gonna make some edible things in our
resins yeah there's so many hotness that
you can add a resonant completely
transform it yes and we could add those
to our people pigments yeah and I'm just
glad that we can use everything would
you rather that we get one free
international flight a year or we both
get to fly domestically for free all
year oh dang because I was like totally
gonna say international okay so here's
my thought process flying domestically
most of the time we're flying it's to
see friends family or collab and
slash event and it's not the price of
the fly loosely it's not too much
friends and family it's mostly collabora
vent okay let's go collaborating with
friends but
it's not outside of YouTube yeah you're
true okay but especially because of that
the price of the flight is never the
issue you know cuz there's a reason
we're going it's it's the time that's
the issue you know it's just time but
going international the the cost is
something that deters us you know one
international flight per year even
though even if monetarily same amount or
even if for all the domestic flights
being free is cheaper I'd say the
domestic one because of the
international because in the case of the
international one the price is often the
reason why we don't do it I mean it was
time to it's okay time is the reason we
don't do it but price is a thing that
weighs on us yeah you know yeah so I'll
do international what do you do and my
arguments are pretty good I know the
same answer for everyone I think that
money is more a factor in my decision
your decisions yeah but I do think like
I think the amount of domestic flights
we do a year probably do add up to the
international yeah you're right
I mean maybe not it's hard because right
now we have like Southwest companion
pass so one of us does fly for free and
sometimes to certain things are our
tickets are paid for yeah sometimes yeah
certain tickets are paid for so I think
I would also do the international
because I feel like you said we're gonna
do the domestic stuff anyway yeah yeah
and it's kind of like that the thing
that's free tastes better
or like enhanced vibes free it's free
then you like have to do it yeah you
have to you have to take our fight man
every answer we've done the same well we
we are kind of like you know I know like
very similar and same person yeah all
right well I think let's do one last one
each and then let's wrap it up okay
sounds good would you rather have one
sponsor and
income is more guaranteed but you're a
little bit more restricted on projects
because you kind of have to link things
to that sponsor or what do you have to
would you rather put time and effort
into getting sponsors and having to
reach out and everything but you have
more flexibility and you know it's it's
a really relevant question because I
think that both are potentials that we
could do you know we can set up long
terms you have one sponsor you mean like
one sponsor for the whole year
yeah let's say that we we found some
crazy opportunity and that sponsor is
like you know what we love you guys
we're gonna sponsor every one of your
videos for this price but you need to
kind of like use one of our products in
it and you know you don't have some
flexibility but you kind of need to
relate it back to this or we just go
about things like regular and let's say
that let's say that even a harsher
restriction you can't do any like
multiple video deals anymore for that
year
what do you mean multiple video like so
with with Lowe's we have you know a six
video deal let's say that you can't do
that every single one has to be
negotiated oh okay okay in that
alternate yeah just to make it smarter
yeah a more extreme yeah so so with the
one company route it kind of depends on
how restricted well unlike what the
company is and what the products are cuz
if the product is you know one of the
like audible Squarespace kind of things
and you just have to do the ad so it's
okay so if it was like you just do an ad
then you wouldn't mind it yeah okay yeah
then I think I might pick that what if
it's like a Tool Company and I'm like
yeah it's like a power tool company yeah
you have to use a power tool and every
single build
hmm I mean I'm trying to think of
there's not too many builds where we
don't use a power tool
at some point if we could if the like it
could be any power tool and we just had
to use it at some point
then maybe I might not probably cuz like
the only videos the videos that we don't
really need to do like when we did the
beard video we didn't use any power
tools but what we could have done is we
could have taped like like a glitter
dispersion system onto cups and then
like spun it on the drill and like my
gut is telling me no do the do the
variation because you don't really
locked in yeah you know like what if you
come up with something where you
couldn't use a power tool yeah but I
feel like even if we brought it in in
kind of a silly way like that like the
first acrylic core video we didn't have
a power tool yeah but like we could ya
like put a like spinning attachment on a
drill and like spin the paint kind of
like you know highlighted the standing
and the drilling in the mountain cut out
the circles of water so yes yeah you
know we can get creative yes I like oh
my gut is saying stick to what we're
doing and just like negotiate he's still
independently but I kind of think if it
was a power tool company and it was just
use a power tool yeah and they had a
super wide variety yeah I think I would
go for that okay now I already know the
answer for this but like let's say it's
like a vacuum Foreman company know
anything specific like less is only
would you have to use wood and every
single project yeah yeah me too if it's
wide enough maybe if it's really wide
great enough then maybe but if it's too
narrow no the only thing I could think
of that would be wide enough would be
like a power tool
grant yeah you know yeah um and it's
really only if they don't have to say in
the I don't have say in the project cuz
if they have say in the project know and
some of our sponsors do have say in in
the project is bad at all
yeah what a month isn't bad but
if every single project had to be
approved because some of our ideas are
like and how do you even describe a okay
so we're gonna make a serving board and
then we're gonna smash tiles and break
it up and and when we did pitch though
we did very vague yeah we did we were
like it'll be a serving boy yeah I don't
know
yeah very under very specific scenario I
would you choose the one company okay
would you rather be unable to use search
engines or unable to use social media
could I find a workaround to the search
engine thing what's your work could I
ask you to use the search engine know
like what's back and and now if I can't
use social media can you know what so
like then then our jobs will be done we
have no jobs
okay well but if I say yes it's too easy
right inconvenience because I have to
ask you to do all of that thing I don't
like either of those scenarios well
would you rather be burdened with for
both of us I didn't turn around
burdening me Yeah right cuz like if it's
neither of us then then then that's
horrible I think but I think it has to
be neither of us oh my gosh like if I'm
asking an individual like let's say
you're a single person yeah and you're
you know you live in your apartment
whatever then access to someone
immediately so if I was a single person
just working a normal job I would rather
give up social media than a search
engine because I feel like search engine
is like so useful and you use that all
the time this is you me personally well
if I wasn't
doing this with you I'm saying this
isn't you in an alternate life we're
together yeah but we are one unit so if
you can't use it I can't use it either
oh okay so both of us had to either give
up search engines per social media we
can look at this we can call people to
do the things higher like a like
personal assistant no what I'd like hire
a personal assistant to send us like
links and information and research
things yeah it'd be a big pain I do not
do that because I do the giving up
search engines okay because we can't
give up social media it's like we'd have
to give up YouTube and you know I'm not
putting YouTube in social media because
I think that's the idea
I don't think YouTube use social media
its media I think of social changes
things as social media the social media
that is Instagram Twitter and Facebook
right now since we could hire we can
have a PA that that does our googling
and research for us could we have a
personal assistant that does the social
media for us right yeah yeah you still
have to call them yeah that's totally
fine really like yeah we just send them
the photos and the text like replying to
comments and stuff but we can reply to
YouTube comments yeah but we can't we
couldn't reply to Instagram or Twitter
we could put out guidelines for our
personal assistants prioritize spongebob
cat
you know and like you know if there are
like at the end of the day let's say
that like the PA calls us and says hey
you got a lot of questions about this a
lot of questions about this and how do
you respond want to respond to this and
we say we give the feedback and she you
know he or she does the the things it
wouldn't be that bad like bigger people
do that do that yeah okay I solved it
found an answer yes all right
good questions questions content cuz
you're going this way you know yeah okay
sorry for people who are just listening
we're we're just like good business
things things like sports sports we
should we should call it because it's
getting laid now
yeah do you want to share your thing of
the week I do want to share my thing of
the week right now I know you are I'm
using mine too they're fuzzy socks and
they're wonderful now I wasn't addicted
to fuzzy socks until I started marrying
Caleb converted me and got me addicted
to fuzzy socks and I all include the
link to mine and Caitlyn's in the
description below but they're far
superior to normal socks
they don't squish you they provide the
proper amount of warmth yes
I never get hot I never get cold in them
they we we wear them often as normal
socks when we can get away with yeah if
I'm wearing pants and my shoes cover
them sometimes when I'm not wearing
pants I'll just wear my fuzzy socks my
new favorite thing is my fuzzy socks and
my pink like adidas dude so Davi folks
call me out for it too and I'm like you
don't understand convert your life cuz
like my feet never used to get cold not
not really no I changed you they were
cold by then
I didn't feel them and now that I've
been wearing fuzzy socks there's someone
from comfortable in the fuzzy stock if
my feet are cold
the room is out she cannot do it I'm
miserable and I can't like I just can't
uncoiled myself there's a big difference
between fuzzy socks and like slipper
socks yeah super socks suck I do not
like the ones with the nubs
fuzzy and yours are black so they like
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
the best okay so my thing of the week is
another podcast and this isn't a new
podcast but it's sounds like it's a new
department not a new podcast a new
podcast but it's one that I really like
um so and it's one that helped inform
our podcast yeah it's one that we we
definitely took some inspiration from so
it's called young house love has a
podcast which I know sounds like a
really random jumbling of words if you
don't know who young house love is but
they had a blog from like oh gosh like
2000 so onward
super early blog the first like home DIY
blog that I started reading and I
followed them religiously they're
posting every day that was like before
daily vloggers were vlog good morning
routine I was like my morning routine I
would read yhl every single day and
they've since cut back on the blog some
but they started a podcast a couple
years ago and it's super cool so if you
like husband-and-wife podcast renovation
home decor DIY yeah they exactly that's
like it in a nutshell and they also play
games which is fun not every episode
like we do and not quite as long exams
but they do you play games which are
super fun we could play some of their
games not super often but they sometimes
will bring on like experts in their
fields to discuss like like like how to
talk to a contractor how to negotiate
early
I mean sometimes that's experts
sometimes it's like people from HGTV
yeah cuz they've been around a long time
here like no a lot of people have a lot
of contact like out there a blogger
sometimes other makers but they're just
super cool their names are John and
Cheri their I feel like I am friends
with them because I've been following
their life for so long which sounds very
creepy but it's a super awesome podcast
and if you're into like home renovation
they're they're currently renovating to
beach houses and they talk about it a
lot on the podcast if you're into like
home DIY design renovation that kind of
stuff or just like goofy husband and
wife things then you will like it so
we'll put a link to that and the fuzzy
socks put a link to their podcast and
their website because they're outside oh
yeah the blogs awesome so we need to say
the things we just did the things like
the like dude the rating and the sharing
and the subscribing and the rating and
though it would be super awesome if you
guys did the rating and the sharing and
subscribing you know what recording
podcasts late at night is dangerous I
feel like we're gonna sound really loopy
in this one okay guys secret thing
listen to this at half speed we're gonna
sound drunk that's that's a thing that I
got from young house loved yeah cuz they
did a special episode called drunk house
love where they played back some of like
conversations they had I don't know how
and I'm not going to try even though I
just said
good funnier when I dislike this play
the hospital
[Music]